des notes de claude françois refont
surface la face cachée de claude
françois vous allez voir c'est assez
hallucinant et sont avec nous fabien
lecoeuvre évidemment vous le connaissez
très bien faire le coeur qui peut
rentrer
[Applaudissements]
silence
en fait
[Applaudissements]
c'est ou soit que j'ai revu des vidéos
sur internet et je vous reconnais veut
dire que vous avez connu claude françois
c'est
incroyable carole et à carole et ketty
quand même c'est assez hallucinant fait
quoi tous les deux aujourd'hui car wash
est restauratrice où ça
72 rue du chevaleret jusque là
qu'est ce qu'il ya sur la carte jaune à
daegu moi je vis de mes rentes de bien
oui possible alors moi j'ai donc et des
notes qui sont ressortis donc
effectivement il faisait beaucoup de
travail et beaucoup au dictaphone et
vous envoyez des notes et les choses qui
m'ont beaucoup beaucoup choqué notamment
sur vous ketty alors kitty vous avez été
engagée en 76 donc deux heures avant sa
mort dont vous voulez un petit peu un
petit peu moins connus il vous
surnommait la banque gala où l'on non
non c'est vrai c'est vrai oui mais vous
choquer pas ça aussi mais pour lui
c'était un jeu veiller en fait comme les
gens ne savaient pas ça ça voulait dire
mangal a way et pour podium pour
m'annoncer
la nouvelle claudette il avait m'avait
surnommé la banque gala la banque gala
aux longues jambes à l incroyable ça et
c'est vrai que vous avez dit aussi ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure alors c'est
l'ubs un pardon je redis tout ça passe
ça paraît tellement fou et encore une
fois c'est peut-être une autre époque je
juge pas avec les lois d'aujourd'hui ce
qu'on faisait à l'époque mais mais c'est
vrai qu'ils aient aussi comme par hasard
vous dansiez un petit peu moins bien si
j'avais voulu quelqu'un qui dans ce
match aurait pris une blanche et la gsi
j'ai pris deux noirs c'est pour que tu
danses commune noir c'est vrai ça oui
non c'était si j'ai engagé une noire
c'est pas pour qu'elles soient plus
raide qu'une blanche oui oui oui il est
gros choc là et la laddh willem à la
chorégraphie le tour de rage savait le
faire et la dernière phrase paraît-il et
qui m'a tellement choqué il paraît que
jour où peut-être ils voulaient plus de
vous et vous aidiez le pouvoir tourner
dans son arbre tout comme ça c'est pas
ça c'était quoi conan des poissons
côtiers j'étais tout le temps en retard
oui tout le temps en retard est tout le
temps en retard sur il y avait une
grosse répétition et je suis arrivé avec
une heure de retard ah oui et claude est
tellement énervé il m'a dit
tu pourrais retourner sur ton cocotier
en fait tu savais pas quoi quoi dire
pour me pour me pour me piquer mais ces
phrases là à l'époque oui elle vous elle
vous heurtez elle voulait trouver ainsi
pas du tout ça me fait pas j'étais
non mais on est au mois de novembre pour
moi je me suis dit je serai mieux
sûrement cocotiers que là parce que là
avec le dock à l'époque c'était pas
raciste mangala la banque galade machin
les bleus n'étaient pas racistes ainsi
l'été passé juste odieux
il était très exigeant mais pas parvenir
à 6 min odieux mais ce qu'il ya c'est
que là on parle que du côté négatif de
claude faut aussi dire tout ce qu'il
avait de positif par rapport à nous où
il était gêné roger sur les flèches
aussi il était généreux ils paient très
bien là non mais tout ça mais c'est vrai
qu'elle me dit quand j'ai lu ces fiches
la gg assez halluciné et vous à carole
avec lui c'était quoi la relation vous
aviez est-ce qu'il était dur pareil
comme ça oui moi il était dur il m'a
viré abidjan parce que j'ai faim on
avait des collants repetto vous savez
les collants et donc c'est trop et avait
juste un petit un petit trou et en plus
j'étais malade savez j'avais j'avais de
la fièvre
et ça m'a pris et il m'a viré navire est
donc abidjan terminée mais est ce que
vous vous disiez chez avec une star et
et c'est normal ils exigent ou est-ce
que vous vous disiez merde il est odieux
quoi ça connaît qu'est ce que vous
disiez oui je râlais mais bon j'étais
tellement jeune je râlais mais en même
temps il était dur mais en même temps il
était fragile en même temps il est
attachant en même temps les bosses ça
râle toujours un peu ah oui mais quand
même quand même ouais mais les gm était
toujours aussi rugby à ludivine romande
au togo côtier à mon avis je pense pas
qu'elle va très bien
voilà je suis d'accord c'est pas bien ah
on est d'accord quand même vous ça vous
choque à l'époque que même moi j'ai le
reste que c'est vrai je le demandais
aussi à fabien ça c'est un ami qui était
fan de claude françois qui les a tous
ses concerts jusqu'en 78 qui m'a raconté
que pendant certaines chansons il
chanter les paroles pour vous faire
passer des messages alors que par
exemple et chanter comme d'habitude tu
es très en retard comme d'habitude tu es
viré demain comme d'habitude c'est vrai
ça ou pas il s'agit des paroles est
beaucoup plus dans les messages est ce
que c'est vrai ça va bien c'est vrai sur
scène quand déjà faut savoir que les
chansons de son répertoire qui faisait
traditionnellement aux ballerines aux
trois et quatre minutes sur scène elle
faisait une minute 50 à peu près il
accélérer le et entre deux du coup ouais
y avait une espèce de rythme s'ils
faisaient quand il se retourne et voyez
si une danseuse avait justement un
problème à son collant si si les
paillettes manqué sur les sur les
maillots si c'était mal et bonne tenue
pour la bonne chanson elle rit profitait
de régler en même temps ses trucs et le
public c'est incroyable parce que c'est
génial il y avait une telle frénésie que
le public se rendaient absolument pas
compte de ça alors donc regarder bien
donc ces fameuses notes qui ressortent
aujourd'hui est forcément un choc alors
par exemple sur son radine isme parce
qu'effectivement était pas très généreux
regardez les notes qui sont ressortis
donc je rappelle que c'était au
dictaphone à pour ceux qui ont un peu
mon âge à l'époque ils seront dix plaies
et puis après des secrétaires qui tapait
à 6 donc je sais pas si vous arrivez à
lire
retient d'office au club à la rochelle
le prochain gala différent parce
qu'elles ont perdu de cintra cinq fronts
voilà le message à l'essai mais
attention mesdames et les choses
qu'elles perdront les romands sont c'est
hallucinant ça c'était vrai il vous
faisait ça et vous
non mais il était jésus re si je peux me
permettre il était tout sauf radin les
concerts il invitait les 25 personnes du
spectacle les invitaient sur sa note
enfin non mais là il en avait marre
parce qu'il rachetait des cintres tout
le temps c'est que la build vers achetez
des cintres en permanence il demandait
mais où passe tous ses centres alors
fabien sur le côté tyrannique on en a
quelques-unes sauf que moi forcément je
ne vous cache pas je ne vois plus rien
même si je ne mets pas du monde pour ne
pas le montrer mais donc merci de les
lire ce qu'ils voient quelque chose
alors voila merci où tous les jeunes des
tests françoise l'énorme vaporisateur
que tu as mis dans le sac à main
la mollet lors entre moi ta mollet smala
je ne suis pas dans la merde laissé
convaincre en soit c'était sa secrétaire
secrétaire jeu 2 betnet françois ça
dénote voilà terminé c'est ça tout le
monde le lendemain il offrait un
bracelet l'une d'un très grand bijoutier
ouais il offrait une montre signée d'un
grand bijoutier aussi ouais c'est à dire
qu'il n'était pas laisser ça pardonne
tout ça c'était sa manière non mais vous
savez le côté tyrannique david bowie
mick jagger ou jackson c'est les mêmes
sont les mêmes mains csq sport non mais
c'est à dire que non vous savez il ya
cette espèce quand vous êtes adulé par
autant de gens comme ça oui qu'on soit
en france en angleterre aux etats unis
ça vous pensez presque intouchable salut
les artistes on les fréquente tous un
peu un moment donné il ya un tel succès
c'est les intouchables s'appelle claude
françois comme les autres c'est-à-dire
qu'on un moment donné ils sont au dessus
des lois presque au dessus de tout et un
espèce de forme de commandement très
curieux alors il n'est que j'ai quand
même vous lire parce qu'elle est
derrière mais effectivement quand il
parle à son chauffeur et dit merci quand
tu prends la voiture de ne pas régler le
rétroviseur de droite de ne pas régler
le rétroviseur central et de ne pas
bouger le siège situé allée jambe plus
courte que moi c'est ton problème
non mais c'est pas méchant c'est pas
méchant mais tu réponds connard les
langages et des secrétaires ces
chauffeurs de voiture qui avait sa
taille oui moi pas bon parce qu'il ne
supportait pas déplacés syriens selon
les rebelles je pense qu'il ya un
paradoxe entre le claude françois à sur
la scène et le contrôle soit dans la vie
privée moi j'ai échangé avec florian
gazan qui est son filleul et qui m'a
raconté que il avait aussi beaucoup de
comportements d'une grande générosité
notamment dans la vie privée par exemple
ils avaient des caves à vin immense avec
des vins exceptionnels alors que lui ne
vivaient pas beaucoup et c'est la
présence de ces vins étaient uniquement
là pour faire plaisir
il crée un alcool de poires aussi
à son nom
sa famille toi tout à l'heure vous
n'arrêtez pas de dire vous n'arrêtez pas
de dire alors oui il était raciste où il
était désarmé il donnait de l'argent
mais il faisait des grosses fêtes mais
nous payer bien mais l'argent c'est pas
comme ça qu'on valorise les gens n'y
avait pas du tout de racisme savait il a
grandi en egypte en côte hill et il
n'aimait que les blacks en chantant en
artiste chanteur très belle voix je sois
otis redding que ce soit jackson il
était fan de tout ça et donc c'est le
première s'accompagnait de danseuses
black d'ailleurs annoncé que je sais
mais ça passe bien c'est aussi comment
parler aux petites gens regardent une
note par exemple il y avait un côté très
maniaque a été obsédé par lord et
regarder les notes qui faisaient pour sa
femme de ménage femme de ménage qui
devait gagner le smic à l'époque ces
voix là j'ai des plus trop longtemps et
ça commence à m'énerver des langues qui
sont brûlés au cassé les mains très
propre il faut avoir les mains très
propre pour faire ça car c'est du
velours il faudrait aussi à ces moments
là la présence de la femme de chambre
afin de bien photographier où se
trouvent les livres et les bibelots pour
les remettre exactement à leur place
d'autre part il ya une bordure du
plafond en velours bleu qui fait des
petites vagues à ces mordus rigidité
ya pas de merci ya pas de gentils n'y a
pas de s'il vous plaît pardon est ce
qu'on peut dire des choses aussi
quelques années après il a du talent si
j'étais un sale type
excuses mathieu may line up il les
faisait au moment où il était furieux a
cédé 7 8 et on à l'époque c'était dans
la voiture
c'est ça alors alors jean michel et puis
après c'est moi encore entendre de nos
deux meilleurs temps des voix en
confident oui marre de ça c'est ça la
retarde ou alors fabien jean michel et
le modèle confidence par exemple les
soirs de pleine lune la femme de 2,2 de
ménage enfin avec l'employée de maison
avaient pour consigne il avait ramené d
ivoire d'afrique il était fasciné par
l'afrique abbas a déjà aussi bien brave
ou non mais si on est dans une autre
époque c'est vrai c'est vraiment dans ta
raison et les soirs de pleine lune vous
savez faut tremper les ivoires dans
l'eau oui pendant toute la nuit et on
les ressort au matin donc là l'employé
de maison avaient espéré cette consigne
là de faire ça ouais là prenez des notes
de service sur les mots j'ai toutes ces
notes bogui sénia a gardé tous ses
agendas toutes ces notes etc et bien je
peux vous dire que la consigne elle
tombait tout les plaines lunes à chaque
fois il fallait trempée sylla l'employée
de maison ne ne faisait pas ça elle l
était viré lendemain oui alors un esprit
c'est pas un mot on peut dire ce qu'on
veut il avait quand même un rapport aux
femmes qui étaient quand même un peu
spécial il faisait des interviews à la
télévision belge notamment wins aimait
les femmes je leur fais l'amour quand
ils ont 15 16 en 2007 ont servi à zenden
et settat et urinaires ou
alors vous savez quoi eh bien on là
c'était ça le fait pas c'était carrément
et puis-je obsédé par la catégorie de
filles qui viennent boire et qu'elles
ont de 15 à 18 ans après 18 ans et des
vieillards n'en parle plus alors je dis
c'est un petit peu c'est en fait c'est
le contraire j'aime ou jusqu'à 7 18 ans
après je commence à me méfier quand les
filles pique des crises assad et rage
retrouve non civilisés mais exactement
comme je les aime nature je pense que
personne prendra les risques une chose
paraît aujourd'hui ce serait extrêmement
mal vécu juste titre mais voilà je pense
que ce qui a changé c'est beaucoup la
société le regard que les gens portent
sur ces choses là
mais le comportement des gens eux mêmes
et ce qu'il a vraiment changé will alain
chamfort qui est derrière sur les jeunes
filles par exemple sabuni voyez
forcément mais les failles
mais soyons honnête j'ai toujours vu
avec avec défiance et sociales et
catherine
l avant il y en avait une autre
s'appelle france bien sûr
de travailler avec claude jamet j'ai vu
des débordements jamais parce que était
très respecté de celle où on est
toujours énervé donc dictaphone comme
vous l'avez bien dit c'est là où ils
balançaient les notes de service mais
j'ai bien après on est tous 10 mai donc
moi je vais pas les les petites sens
alors alors ça je vais je vais pas
l'enfoncer ça je vais pas l'enfoncer
parce que je pense que franchement le
sarde où les hallyday tout ce je n'ai
pas non plus mais les petites fans qui
attendent en bas je pense que parfois le
montet
[Musique]
oui complètement si les coauteurs c'est
ce qu'ils n'ont pas vu dans le public
regardez ce film c'est un des meilleurs
films français de saur 2 millions
d'entrées sur tout ça dit tout quoi tout
le mec il est effectivement bar et un
rapport avec son père qui est très
complexe il a rapport à l'amour qui est
compliqué il a l'impression que personne
n'aime jamais les gens il a morflé et en
fait c'est un psychorigide très anxieux
presse dans le salon europa généraux se
trouvait marcherait mais à ce point là
se trouvait moche mais vous savez
on se trouve être l est les jambes
arquées vous trouvez que
ça n'allait pas est ce que vous aviez
peur de lui elle se bat vous et des
répétitions je sais pas vous aviez le
voir non je me sens bien régulièrement
et puis lavez et j'ai juste un petit os
que ludivine en revanche côté les
retraites très fâché sur le côté un peu
un fret un peu raciste qu'on a l'air au
dessus de banaliser l'action mais vous
êtes ma grand mère était très fan ma
grand mère et sa mère à elle était
d'ailleurs bretonne donc moi je suis
totalement mélanger donc je parle j'ai
pas d'à priori c'est ma je me sens pas
blessé dans ma chair mais je suis désolé
il faut arrêter bien sûr que c'est
assumer quand on entend des personnes
telles que pepita ou quoi qu'ils disent
mais non mais ces personnes n'étaient
pas racistes on nous traitait très bien
je suis désolé retourne dans ton
cocotiers tu viens pas danser ici parce
que j'ai pas pris noir pour qu'elle
danse qu'elle soit plus raide qu'une
blanche bien sûr que c'est raciste bien
sûr que même s'il n'avait pas un
comportement pour vous l'être dans une
cage ou vous mettre dans une jeune mais
c'était un comportement racisme on était
vachement lait peut pas les seules
images
l'époque est à l'époque c'était de bon
ton de naître oui oui mais ça c'était
avant ce parce que lui tu te rendes
michel leeb qui disait c'est pas mes
narines s'aimer ray-ban moi de faire
cette base aujourd'hui mais voilà il est
pourtant il cartonnait faisait
l'olympien
absolument vous voulez vous l'avez
connue moi je les connais la fin de son
existence puisque j'étais en stage et en
école de presse ouais j'ai failli
rentrer chez lui ça c'est pas fait
malheureusement à deux mois près mais je
l'avais un jour poser une question parce
que vous savez qu'en dehors des plateaux
de télévision on ne voyait jamais les
yeux de claude françois ça y est le
tueur ses ray ban sur le nez évidemment
et que ce soit alors heureusement son
bureau le voyait sans lunettes et puis
en télé bien sûr et sur scène sans
lunettes sinon il se cachait toujours
derrière ses lunettes et moi un jour
j'ai eu cette délicate question parce
que je vouvoyais évidemment et je disais
mais pourquoi claude vous portez des
toujours des ray-ban comme ça sur le net
tassement la genève après une émission
de télé et puis il m'a dit tu dois
savoir que le regard d'une star ne doit
jamais croisé le regard d'un autre et
aujourd'hui si vous regardez le star
system de mylène farmer de toutes ces
immenses stars c'est exactement ça
sature allez c'est à dire alors ils
avaient conscience de son star system ce
qui l'était ce qu'il représentait faut
se remettre dans le contexte progressera
et johnny c'était les deux leaders qui
se partageaient la france entière et
j'aime entendre demain vous a montré
jusqu'à dernier parce que ça faisait un
petit portillon ça me choque un peu sur
les plombiers si on l'a juste parce que
moi ce qui m'a choqué c'est comme il
parlait au petit entre guillemets on
avait un dernier sur les plombiers
traite son plombier d'imbéciles je sais
pas si on l'a ou pas limite moi c'est ça
qui me dérange un peu là on a vu tout à
l'heure
alors que je ses nombreuses fraudes que
j'avais qu'elle ne coule plus mais par
contre il a été malheureux vis et
comment voyez pas là butin que pombie
c'est un imbécile et un mauvais mois ce
qui me dérange c'est ça il parlait mal
aux petits et pas les bulles on
s'applique à lui-même aussi parce que
florian m'a dit aussi que par exemple
quand il arrivait au moulin il y avait
donc une pelouse magnifique
sa musique avec des gravats qu'ils
allaient là avant même de dire bonjour à
qui que ce soit il allait retirer les
trois gravats qui avait dans la pelouse
autour donc opaque qui s'appliquera
aussi à lui-même un coup de main ce
dernier mot parce qu'on doit rendre
florian je voulais dire quoi ou non
cette marge est juste une petite
anecdote mais qui est un peu long et
alors là tu la gardes pour derrière et
tout ça moi ce que j'aimerais surtout
c'est remercier ses deux anciennes
progrès vers vous êtes toujours aussi
belle merci d'avoir été récup et de le
défendre ses travaux à samedi prochain
dès 9h10 et la 17e place
[Applaudissements]